I just bought some grapes the other day
and those came from Spain well I'm like
how'd they get all the way from Spain
and still look this green better not ask
those questions I'm vegan and I Drive an
electric car I do shop at Amazon quite
frequently
though I am also began's I do eat meat
and dairy and I know that that affects
it a lot I bike to work I'm a vegetarian
I don't really think my lifestyle is too
crazy the one thing that I haven't been
able to kick that I would really like to
is Amazon Amazon is so convenient but my
goodness they put so much packaging so
this test is called the footprint
calculator test how often do you eat
animal based products it breaks it down
by each individual animal product that's
interesting I went vegetarian it used to
be very often but right now is limited
to dairy sometimes I like a burger so
I'm vegetarian so I'm gonna go with
occasionally I don't eat any of them
ever I guess I switch off on beef and
poultry so I guess I'll go watch it
twice a week how much of the food that
you eat is unprocessed unpackaged or
locally grown so I both been in farmer's
market for almost all of my diet except
for when I'm at work I would say the
majority of what I purchase would be
packaged because it's mostly from like
the grocery stores I think everything
that I buy comes in a package 45% of my
diet is fresh on packaged food I do try
to eat a lot of fresh vegetables but you
know what some of the vegetables are
packaged I don't go to farmers markets
that regularly which I feel like is
where you get like the local stuff which
housing type best describes my home yeah
I'm definitely in a luxury condominium
you know I'm definitely I would be a
multi-story apartment as well I just
moved two weeks ago into a free-standing
house and I have a house as well I live
in an apartment building that has about
eight units so it's pretty small yes
eimai apartments also small do you have
electricity in your home I sure do yes
I do how energy-efficient is your home I
might say above-average my house is made
in the 40s that seems like the worst
span for like energy efficiency I'm
gonna say an efficiency centered design
because it has like one of those little
nest things that like adjusts it I don't
know
compared to your neighbors how much
trash do you generate again it's Amazon
I swear it's just a man a lot of people
or Amazon compared to my neighbors I'm
probably about the same we Democrat our
bin size and I think we're about 25
percent of what we use to produce we get
a lot of like junk mail and I do shop
online a lot so I do get a lot of trash
that way and they package everything
individually and then and they're like
it's a lot of packaging and like cooking
and I have a dog we do generate a lot of
trash sadly I don't get a lot of mail or
packages and I also compost we do like a
freezer compost how far do you travel by
car or motorcycle each week I try to
take the bus in the Train and all that
kind of stuff I Drive and I liked your
car I Drive a Nissan Leaf his name is
Leif Ericson oh I'm gonna say like 100
and I don't have a motorcycle I bike to
work four days a week we're both not
cool how far do you travel on public
transportation Age week I'm gonna have
to give this a hard zero ever since I
got a car and I got to meet enough
exciting people on the public
transportation a lot you do think you do
meet some exciting I don't take public
transportation in LA mine's zero I
literally don't know how to take public
transportation how many hours do you fly
each year if I'm flying I usually fly
either to like the Seattle area see
family or over to the East Coast past
two years I've only been going to like
Mexico so well say eight hours usually I
don't fly that much my family out in
Colorado if we do fly for fun sometimes
sadly I feel like I flew to a lot of
weddings last year I flew 11 times last
year
most of those were cross-country flights
if everybody live like me we would need
to Earth's yeah but you're doing way
better than me
it says if everyone lived like you we
need 2.6 Earth's 2.7 earths 1.7 earths
so you're a better person than me 3.1
earth if everyone lived like you we need
3.3 earths it's a lot of Earth's and
this one is already so because of flying
it gives you a breakdown of your
footprint food and mobility or my big
issues right now so yeah a lot of - for
mobility and you know it's not from my
electric cars so it's all from the
flying if everybody lived like you earth
overshoot day would be on this day this
means by this state we would have used
as much from nature as Earth can renew
in the entire year so I'm only making it
to the 31st of July no you're making it
further than me I'm dead before then all
right so we're not feeling too good
right now so let's explore some
solutions so on the solutions page of
this quiz they have a bunch of different
links to show you how you can kind of
lower your footprint my biggest carbon
footprint is coming from food that is
definitely something that I could
probably do more in doing that I kind of
feel like it'll help me be a little bit
healthier you can work with your
governments to help advocate for cleaner
policies noble energy I need to figure
out ways to fly less I mean it'd be
great to find new ways to like get
around and driving every single time and
then also goods for me was higher than
my mobility so like finding new ways of
getting things maybe order online less
I'm a little surprised at my results I
thought I was living like fully
sustainably but like I'm still producing
more carbon than this planet can take so
I think there's a lot of room for
improvement oh I got a lot of scar
awesome
[Music]